ricky you're uh you're from where
where's your family
in mexico so so you're yourself you
consider yourself a conservative
capitalist
my my my all my dad was an entrepreneur
i've never heard my dad call anybody
boss
no any of his brothers and sisters my
dad's an entrepreneur
and we are conservative in we love our
country we love god
we love our families and we like our
rights protected i mean it's it's it's
i think every hispanic doesn't realize
they're conservative or every latino at
least or
everybody in general but i think mostly
for us from where we come from
it's family god make your money take
care i mean it's it's the
very basics so as a as a hispanic i'm a
more
a more and where by the way we're pro
we're pro uh pro-life
right because as a matter of fact a lot
of people don't know that some people
might agree some people might agree i
know some parts
of the catholic religion depending where
you live do not even allow people to use
condoms which makes sense why our
grandparents had so many kids so we are
about life
and i'm looking at a lot of you know
modern hispanics or progressive
hispanics
that don't want god involved right in in
the system
don't have a big problem whenever you're
talking about pro-life or pro-choice
and and they're getting they're getting
away from the values of principles that
our grandfather
our grandparents and our parents taught
us so the ones that want to treat with
that
i'm a latino often hispanic rasa if
you're really that way
then you are naturally conservative you
remember when george w
ran for uh his second term as texas
governor
it was a hispanic landslide here in
texas
landslide by the hispanic community
right so i mean you you are absolutely
correct i grew up in san antonio texas
but you're absolutely correct
that it is it is all about god and
family it is a great point why why
do you think i mean you you get into
with your community a lot of times you
get into it all the time
all the time you know you you've
converted a lot of people to get into
the way of thinking of who they really
are but
why do you think a lot of hispanics it's
the fastest growing community in america
population wise voting wise i mean it's
the future the way it's going right now
demographics what
yeah demographic why do you think they
vote 64
vote democracy so i i have to go a
little deeper okay so
my dad when my dad was 15 years old
living in mexico the bible was only
spanish
i mean we don't speak spanish
the bible in mexico was latin
up until my dad was 50 years old my dad
is he was born in 1957 so figure up into
the late 60s early 70s the bible was in
was not in spanish it was in latin okay
but the catholic religion or just
religion in general in mexico
has been there since after that they
killed the aztecs of the mayans
so the reality is this my dad says i
don't even know why i followed a certain
religion
it's just because they told me hey this
is the bible kissed him and said there's
a word of god
so what what does it teach us about
hispanics we're very trusting you
right so we might not even be able to
read it but if you've seen enough time
by the way hitler said it say the lie
repeat the lie don't believe the lie
right almost like i'm talking about the
religion i'm just saying
as a hispanic community in mexico we're
very trusting when you say we want to
help you
we're very trusted so whenever you jump
on the news like telemundo
and you listen to jorge ramos which is
supposed to be for us and you say
this is orange man bad you're like yes
you do you don't do your homework you
don't do your research
you don't you don't dig deeper just
because another man with your same skin
color from your same country
that is also an immigrant says so you
believe him that's the problem with the
hispanic community
nobody goes deeper everybody just says
oh mexican
must have my my interest in my best
interest at heart
i'm gonna believe him so when you start
looking at uh you know we're reading
through all the laws and
everything you know for example i mean
here we are we have hispanics voting for
the man that was a vice president well
four million people got deported the
most in history
on top of that the cages were built when
he was a vice president
so you're talking about rasa you if
you're trump you're bad
you're you're a traitor but you were
voting for the man that was vice
president for eight years
as our people got deported and built the
cages you're hypocritical but you don't
only better because
jorge ramos told you not to believe that
well i mean so i i i will speak in
defense of many
people from mexico who are not too
terribly impressed with the idea of a
wall
100 100 so i'm just just just saying
i i said it i said it yesterday i posted
on facebook a lot of people the wall is
racist
every single president has added to the
wall right every president
barack obama said that he was going to
go against he the anchor baby
he's the one that brought it up so as to
why i put it on facebook issues okay if
you don't believe in the wall you don't
believe in ice which is
basically the security the the cops of
the border it's very simple
open put on social media with your
addresses open up your windows open up
your doors and don't call the cops when
strangers come into your house
because they might be hard-working
americans that sounds like new york city
these days
that's and it makes sense why why
they've converted so many people but
if you don't like a wall and it it look
do the do the do the
the the trial at your house first before
you want us to open up our country
why don't you open up your house first
go open up your doors your windows leave
them open all day all night let anybody
come in
go to your refrigerator take your food
do whatever sleeping in whatever room
they want
and just not know who they are don't ask
them for id don't ask them for
blood don't ask because who knows i mean
they might just be good hard-working
americans ricky do
they take the newscaster series ramos
still has that much power as an anchor
a news anchor to a certain extent is
equivalent to a
to a to a priest because you just think
they're hispanic they're the i watch
you're gonna think this from the morning
to the end
they watch the morning news telenovelas
which are so popular
people live for tonight in the hispanic
community it is
it is the i grew up around like one of
my crushes her name is rui some of
my hispanic followers are gonna remember
it was a soap opera called ruby
and so they watch these people from
morning to night
so they almost allow them into their
homes it's my dream job to be on a soap
opera
oh my god you look like a soap opera guy
i mean if you look at that he looks
yes so you said you think the wall is
racist
no no no i said hispanics think the
world is
every every sovereign country has a wall
and so they should okay cool
i'm with you i said multiple times that
people like you that look like you tied
it up gangsters i might say
need to actually join the republican
party which you are
and run for office right you can talk
about it all you want unless you run for
office and someone sees
damn that dude ricky is my guy it's all
just
mouth talk right now just take a look
when someone like you runs for office
that's when people are gonna wake up
okay that's number one
number two but this is the truth though
because major is running for
for office right now and you don't see a
whole lot of california he's running
against losing he's a black republican
that's i'm not talking about i'm talking
about latinos but the black community is
just as tight as our community
so if they were that if that was the
case then why isn't major making any
noise in california
well let's talk about numbers now okay
pat said 65 was 64 65
of latinos vote for the democrats that's
35 republican
90 of african americans vote democrat
right
okay what is trump doing i see what
you're saying what is trump doing
to bring more latinos into the
republican party
what is trump doing to bring more
african-americans
right into the community because in my
opinion he's not helping no he
i agree with you adam his link here's
the thing you gotta remember
hispanics are very emotional people you
know who else is emotional yes
everybody everybody no okay but latinos
for sure they were extra emotional like
we cried on the soap operas
doesn't make sense
the problem is the problem is in the
hispanic community
we take things that we shouldn't take as
serious very serious
and things that we that we should take
seriously not as serious so i'm sitting
here i was having a conversation with
the with an individual yesterday on
facebook as well
through messenger if i could show you
all the bills in the laws and everything
that
trump has done to help the hispanic
community
would would that change your mind no why
because f
trump
my wife is right here that's why i love
being married to a mexican woman because
you're very passionate
but that passion comes at a cost yeah
she'll cut you is that that passion is
going to come at a cost
so sometimes erica just just put away
the knife she just
she sometimes she just thinks about it
you're not related to lorena bobbitt no
no
he's checking so erica just may think of
something that i might like
are you don't you think about i was
guilty i started you know so again
uh what she woke up in the middle of the
night because she had a bad dream and
just slapped just slapped the crap out
of me you're like i'm sleeping oh yeah
obviously i'm like did you hit me for
something i might do but here's the
problem here's the problem let's get
back to the point
the point is this and when you when you
talk about the hispanic community
and you think about this like i said uh
uh trump is not appealing
to minorities because his language so
what's the first thing he ever said the
first thing he ever said ricky what was
it let's build a wall you want to build
a wall not to build a wall
that these people are coming across the
border they're rapists
they're drug dealers those are those are
sound bites those are sound bites that
was his first
speech that was his inauguration
ms13 gang rape women in and some other
initiations are to gang rape
gang rape or to murder so so if i grab a
bunch of sound bites
and say oh you you grab he said they
were racist
murderers drug dealers and he says i'm
assuming some people are good
well let me let me i'll put you this way
if i'm at your door with 15 different
people i said adam let me in but you
don't know any of them
are you going to assume they're all good
or that you're going to or you're going
to say i don't know any of you guys
you can i can't i can't assume that
you're good i have to assume that you're
going to harm my family
inside my house all right so let's step
back for a minute
two times now in public trump has been
given the opportunity to
to denounce white supremacists
[Music]